[Music]
so much the top my thanks for being here
tonight Steve you you fit in well in
this whole environment now new Vanity
Fair just came out it's about The
Sopranos it's talking about you know all
you have the whole story of how the show
came together yeah yeah and and and it
shows become such an icon still after
all these years in television and one of
the things that says in the article
which fascinated me is when you first
were approached to play a Bobby bacala
you were worried that you weren't big
enough that you weren't heavy enough is
that true yeah because I had audition
for the show and then I saw the script
came in and you know Tony Soprano was
calling me a calzone with legs and a fat
bastard and uh you should consider
eating salads and I go well I'm not much
fatter than he is you know so at first I
thought stay hired the wrong guy you
know and then they called me and said
you know you have to wear a fat suit
oh you're wearing a fat suit the first
two seasons I wore a fat suit and so I
went I went to it like a Broadway one of
these places they make the costumes and
they gave me a fat suit with your zip in
you step in
zip up I had tits I had a big ass you
know it's it's like a leotard with extra
pad solutely it was absolutely
ridiculous and I had a parade in front
of the producers and you know you know
see if they liked it you know and then
the the fourth season they saw me and
they said you know what you don't have
to wear the fat suit what are you gonna
do now you know what's interesting is
you've said in interviews that because
you played that role in such an iconic
role people feel like they know you
they're very comfortable strangers
commenting on your weight absolutely
absolutely what you know when you're fat
people think they could say anything to
you you know
I just experienced it just now
[Applause]
they can say anything so how my wife's a
marathon runner actually wearing the
half marathon so I went with her to pick
up register you know register and get
the bib and all that so I mean with all
these marathon runners and I've been
literally the guy goes I know you're not
running big boy you know what's the hell
are you doing here you know it's like
they're heckling me all I mean I'm with
my wife you know yeah and then I'm
looking at some clothes for you know
like sweatshirts and stuff lady comes up
to me there ain't nothing in there in
your size and I'm going like you know
and then woman being that's okay this is
true story look I'm in a cab right I'm
in a cab going downtown I'm in New York
City with my wife I said you don't drop
me off on the corner I'm gonna walk the
I goes yeah the cab driver maybe you
should walk you knock off a few pounds
look at your wife she's skinny look at
me I'm skinny the guy smells like a
billy goat he's talking about my way I
tell you sorry man it's absolutely
unbelievable it's terrible when it goes
New York though so maybe that's
everybody you want to drink calling